hey guys Ryan Wright is here and Elissa
be crazy so today we're gonna check out
this video from Elite daily woman draw
their perfect penis now normally when a
woman draws a penis it does end up
looking exactly like mine so the perfect
penis I'm assuming is me when I'm erect
I have the perfect direction not too big
where it's gonna hurt you not too small
we can't feel it all right do you want
me to describe my perfect penis I think
sex is very important in a relationship
there needs to be a strong physical
connection you're not good and bad it's
kind of stuff I would say my ideal penis
size ah like 7 inches 6 inches 7 people
always say 8 inches 9 that's a killer 10
inches is the ideal penis size big
penises are evil I think I saw one
uncircumcised one yeah ideal yes oh my
gosh Oh God
you really want me to do that I wouldn't
really know where to go with that
another I wouldn't not sure what to do
my idea okay toes
how did I see it this morning this is
actually my favorite thing to do is to
drop a person well I've seen many I've
seen many I have to use the rule to see
how big that is
so like Phoenix black a hmm it needs to
be a little bit of girth here this is
like curve upward
Mrs T I will put on their own school
wait now it's gotten taken I need a
bigger starting again I think I'm just
drawing my friends pretty nice great
this is the nice penis yeah they're very
humorous cuz I'm treated cuz I've been
treating him right I do love me some
tiny balls that seems I feel like that's
about right oh yeah I'm Argus over here
I haven't had this in a very long time
oh yeah this is my hairy penis that was
[ __ ] out I think I'm gonna draw my
ex-boyfriends penis size from any peeps
different ideal use any piece that was
weird the base difference between our
lives and the lives you can ban
Instagram is that you can't like
Photoshop your ass in real life yep do
you do Wahby okay so um very interesting
that's hilarious
women draw interesting penises I can't
draw a penis I've tried and I'm not good
at it it just looks like a stick figure
alright yeah some kind of childish
cartoon but not so childish because
that'd be weird what's the ideal penis
size for you I don't even know I just
let me let me just say like I read
online the other day there's this guy
who actually exists he has like a 9 inch
long three inch wide 7 pound dick that
must be so uncomfortable if that's not a
I don't think it's natural I think he
does something to it I don't know why he
would I mean as a guy wouldn't that just
be like the worst thing to carry around
well there's a weird thing about having
a big penis like you do feel more cocky
ha cocky you do feel more cocky with it
I've listened to a lot of like
there's a show called Loveline which is
like a radio section show a lot of
people call in not complaining about
small penises but complaining about big
penises how they like really hurt how
they can't fully penetrate because it
just it goes too deep guys that's what
you don't want comment misconception
don't want a big dick yeah no it scares
women away it does it actually yeah I've
heard that like from not just on a radio
but also from like people I know that
big penises actually are not a
preference no they're not that's why
Veronica loves me I'm not the big I love
this guy he can own anything it's kind
of Awesome yeah I'm Italian and Filipino
so like I tell people Italians or huge
Asians are small same brain between
between and then I go in between yeah
yeah but yeah I mean it's interesting
seeing these different women say like oh
I prefer this size I prefer this size or
like ideals 10 inches I know one girl
with a tenant who has it's one girl with
the dead well I know one girl has a
boyfriend with a 10-inch penis 9 or 10
inches and she says it's pretty painful
but I hear she gives amazing [ __ ]
for girls to know they have to have a
lot of practice like they said it in the
video you need like a mental like
emotional connection for it to be good
and put that many people to compare
between its I just don't see how it
would work well you know no sappy I also
need a certain kind of vagina to handle
a big penis - mmm you know yeah and I
don't think the average vagina can
handle a huge penis no isn't the average
vagina will be like 6 inches deep or
something I don't know and that's that
makes sense is your average penis size
is 6 inches 5 and 1/2 yeah but I've also
heard that the depth of the vagina is
different geographically just like penis
sizes are as well I mean it makes sense
because you know if geographically
people in a certain area have larger
Pinay then you know it makes sense for
the women to have deeper páginas so I
mean it just kind of depends on yours
City - I think I like deep vaginas
that's good it's a baby alright I think
of pictures i watch this channel anyway
guys thanks for saying that videos out
love getting and signing the things like
that if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
you could check out Alyssa be crazy
channel where she does challenges and
stories and I tell you funny things
about my life some of my things don't
seem real but I assure you they are cuz
my life is very strange which is so
crazy and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
promoting those things because if we get
to a server man of followers product
placement
product placement you see they say don't
talk about it but see Tyrone Magnus is
like 1 million subscribers and I'm like
product please